GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
parole, Québec solidaireché la e
pour embaucher une maison je
pense que je les renverrai pour
bris de contrat.
que la Dozois raison de
dire que la claque n'a pas
qu'elle ne l'avait promis.
- Oui, c'est vrai. En 2010, la
plate-forme de la CAQ ne
contenait aucun engagement
Dans une lettre envoyée à dessye
défenses des locataires, la
engagée à terminer la
construction de 14 000 logements
annoncés par le gouvernement
dernier bilan de la société
d'habitation du Québec, c'est
5700 logements sociaux et
construits depuis 2018. Même si
être livré dans les prochains
mois, on est bien loin des 14
quatre ans.
chef, Coalition avenir Québec
- Les 15 000 logements sociaux
et abordables sont financés,t, n
train d'être construit. Le
prochain budget, le gouvernement
indique la construction de 8éjàt
toujours pas commencé à la
décembre.
Les coûts de construction ptrucr
un logement social ont explosé
dans les
À Montréal par exemple, sont
passées  286 000
dollars par unité. Plus la
construc
coûte cher. En ce moment Québec,
inscrits sur la liste d'attente
pour avoir une place dans un
de permet un Paillé avec pou